[Music]
so some of you fans of the show might be
aware of this but my number one dream
guests for the Pete Home Show without a
joke is Ryan Gosling I love Ryan Gosling
yeah when I brought that up you weren't
happy you were concerned you're like
he's at it again
I love Goss I love daddy Goss and I I've
actually taken the matter into my own
hands and we're gonna show you this now
this is a segment we call you'll see why
go in for Gosling you know hey Ryan this
is uh this is Pete Holmes I'm a huge
huge fan I really can't stress that
enough I I'm sorry to call you directly
but I got your number from Andy Richter
show you didn't he didn't give it to me
he left it out and you know seize the
day
as Robin Williams said anyway you are my
dream guest you are the number one guest
that I want to have on the show please
come on the show it's a late night show
it's on after Conan please say yes call
me back it's been oh hi you've reached
keep leaving me hey I got your message I
know you are running your show please go
to my age
I am I got your message not not to call
you sorry it's hard to call you to tell
you that I will stop calling you I I
just can't help but feel like there's a
connection there you know what I mean I
I am all about respecting the correct
avenues to pursue a guest and I think
it's interesting that we so we have that
in common
I mean we doesn't even have to be the
show we could we can hang out you know
if we go get a beer I don't even drink
beer you seem like a beer guy like it
leaned on a car you know
dirty dirty rag and beer and then later
you class up you class it real good
let's hang let's hang maybe look at
chopper vests okay call me back just
like it a joke you're making fun of mess
I love the best doing jackets for those
fleas that's not the way to get me on
the show just did you know are
you doing this calling movie stars
making fun of their vest please don't
call me again Ryan I am mortified I'm
mortified
and this misunderstanding I I did not I
wasn't making fun of you and that's I
love s you're right they do they do look
like jackets without sleeves and you
look great in a man I love you that's
one of our writers a lot of fan a lot of
fancier please pick out your best vest
and come on the show if you don't know
again with the vest but I don't even
know why I'm calling you back I got
better things to do okay like Eva Mendes
yeah from pitch and I don't even know
why you're not answering I mean who
doesn't answer the phone when Jocelyn
coach answered the phone but you're not
talking to the cute notebook counseling
right now you're talking to drive gas
when I'm over there put you in an
elevator and stomp you still until it's
part of the carpet you understand me
never call me telnet jaimegirl
wanna
oh whatever thanks for this point you
know it's always good to meet a nice fan
all right so to recap paint
don't call me Jamie you can call me I
mean he's a plus sign because I'm in
Canada
I'm waiting any girl where's my where's
my gloves with the cut off fingers wave
my well
[Applause]
[Music]